[Music]
oh okay well that's the new york stuff
so you're gonna like this one
the left is not okay and i'm going to
explain why
this guy's a lefty as you're about to
find out
it's like voucher it's a vouch phenotype
yes it's like vaush and beardson had a
[ __ ] love child
so
check this out
i'm i'm not going to shut up about this
i'm not because i can't yell at the
republicans they're not going to change
they are who they are we're stuck with
them we're not going to change them you
can't shame them you can't convince them
you can't trick them
you sound frustrated
you can't shame them they're he's
admitting that the tough they try can't
threaten their families you can't
doctors we don't have guns so we can't
stick those in their face and they have
guns even if we had guns they'd have
guns
so what do we do and we don't know how
to use the guns they've been using them
for years
you can't [ __ ] out plan them but i
can yell at the democratic party and i
can tell them where they can at least
make one [ __ ] small change to stop
pissing me the [ __ ] off every hour right
now that's good because stop
that that's you know the
top priority at the white house right
now is how to not piss off alex from
tick-tock
stop sending me
stop sending me fundraising requests
right now
that's another mask slip moment because
a lot of them are thinking that way
right now nope the the the money's not
flowing in like it usually is
okay the republican party had a plan for
the last 50 years to overturn roe v wade
we had a leak five weeks ago telling us
that this exact thing was gonna happen
and your response after five weeks of
careful study and planning and thought
has been
to send us non-stop fundraising emails
all right so let me just leave you a
quick list mark warmer mark warner
he's the democratic senator from
virginia he's worth 214.1 million
dollars don beyer he's a democratic
virginia house member he's worth 124.9
million dollars dean phillips he's the
he's a minnesota uh house member he is
worth 123.8 million oh yeah
sucks doesn't it
really is that what's happening
you know look and that's one of those
things where and that's one thing i
don't think i've ever done in my
lifetime and i never will do
is i will not give money to a candidate
i don't give them money because it's
no you can go [ __ ] yourself i'll i'll
support you i'll promote you of course
i'll debate people on your behalf and
i'll try to get hearts and minds over
under the good guys side
but even desantis isn't getting a
[ __ ] penny of my money now if he
sells like an exclusive edition shirt or
a hat right that's different because
then i'm like i'll buy the shirt that's
cool
but you dude these [ __ ] aren't
going to die on my money this [ __ ]
got all roped into anti-trump [ __ ] in
the last couple oh yeah and he probably
gave them so much of his hard-earned
[ __ ] lines
he fought the good fight and he gave 15
here and 25
there and 35 dollars here and he just
kept giving until it hurt and now
they're losing they're ruining this
country his money's worth less and
they're like hey bro give me more of
your worthless money i know we just
printed like three trillion dollars and
spent it all
let me hold a couple dollars
he's the democratic senator from
virginia he's worth 214.1 million
dollars oh don beyer he's a democratic
virginia house member he's worth 124.9
million dollars questions sure
how much are you working with alex
perlman
i think he doesn't make enough to get
taxed
dean phillips he's the he's a minnesota
uh house member he is understand he
probably gets paid for most of his jobs
with weed like you know it's one of
those things
half and wheat half of cash yeah worth
123.8 million dollars nancy pelosi the
speaker of the [ __ ] house of the
democratic party from california
until he finds out it's gonna be he's
gonna buy it's gonna blow his [ __ ]
time here we go we just did this we
literally just did this
114.7 million dollars dianne feinstein
who doesn't know where the [ __ ] she is
right now
he's not happy
he's not happy
somebody's figuring it out this is great
to watch
the senator from california part of the
democratic party is worth 87.9 million
dollars
million
you guys want money
[ __ ] call your guy
you call them every week to do insider
trading
oh he's had it
remember when we were on infowars today
you're saying you know every once in a
while there's some people that are
starting to figure it out this guy's one
of those guys look he's never going to
vote republican right but this is gonna
be one of those guys that might just not
vote again which is still a win right
it's a net zero at that point
he'll still come back around and vote
yeah you're right but he's not gonna
give him any more money i bet which
helps a little which helps a little bit
stop [ __ ] sending me emails stop
sending me [ __ ] texts
stop [ __ ] reading poems and singing
goddamn karaoke
i can't this is my favorite video i
think i've ever seen in my days are you
gonna say stop doing makeup tutorials oh
[ __ ] hey come on yeah what else
you have power you have it you're in
those seats we're the ones who are
powerless
stop [ __ ] pretending you're
protesting
see the difference between us and you is
that we believe we're more powerful than
them that's the difference you guys
they've already resigned they've
resigned a long time ago we're powerless
and see the problem is like you know you
think about gun ownership or you think
about like you know why don't they
oppress the common man more it's about
gun ownership it's about dick it's about
people but it's it's also about they
know the minute they start
the minute they take that final like
over step and they really want to try to
take guns physically and have a showdown
people they know they're gonna be that's
the beginning of losing yes everyone's
gonna go oh wow they done did it now
but yeah you just think like i don't
know you're the rich jewish 80 year old
[ __ ] person with 100 million can't
you help
if you don't want to [ __ ] do it or
it's too hard
[ __ ] retire you're rich as [ __ ]
you don't need to do anything if i had
114 dollars you'd be way better you had
a hundred and fourteen dollars you would
be so pumped i am flush
point seven million dollars treat
yourself to chipotle tonight
wait with the with the clock dancing no
that's too expensive they're out of guac
there's no guac there's a sign at every
tree and there's no lettuce they're
mixing it with cabbage due to a shortage
of
avocados um we're you know
no we don't have enough oh i do first
thing i get my [ __ ] husband a driver
so we didn't get a goddamn dui
second thing you know what i do i'd be
on a [ __ ] boat i'd be on a [ __ ]
boat
can i agree with him i don't like this
guy a lot but i will agree i would also
like to be on a [ __ ] boat can we be
on a [ __ ] boat the problem is the
upkeep no no no no i don't think you
hear me i don't want to own a boat okay
i want to be on a floor you have 88
million
you own a boat yeah but then you have to
worry about the upkeep if you have 88
million
114.7 million dollars and you want to
send me a [ __ ]
anyway he seems angry i don't think he's
very happy guys
i believe he's the opposite of that